rubber face comedian jim carrey made his
mark with roles like the mask
ace ventura and lloyd christmas that's
ironic
but in 2000 he made an absolutely
grueling transformation into
the the the grinch which is celebrating
its 20th anniversary
take a look
[Applause]
hot crowd hot crowd i mean just the
costumes alone there's
hundreds of costumes right hundreds of
costumes incredible sets
unbelievable special effects to take
care of 20 years ago how the grinch
stole christmas made our hearts grow
three sizes when it hit the big screen i
love
you ron howard's whimsical adaptation of
the dr
seuss classic has become a true staple
during the holiday season
yes this christmas music
it's joyful and triumphant it was fun to
play once we got in that cave when we
got in those places
you know even with the suit right you
know you just uh
you just can't help but get carried away
with this stuff the grinch is a great
character
it's a terrific christmas fable you know
the chance to
to to work with jim carrey um
playing the grinch was just uh you know
i mean it was it was a christmas present
there was lots of improv you know there
was like the moment of the
behind the screen dressing thing that
was not a planned thing it was
just you know i just thought you know be
funny to just
you know have this monster
transformation that you want to see how
it turns out
5 30 6 30 dinner with me
i can't cancel that again seven o'clock
wrestle with myself loading i'm booked
while filming the cast and crew admired
watching carrie bring the grinch to life
when he came on with the green
prosthetic and the
green dyed yak hairs and just
transformed himself he's such
he's such a powerful performer when he's
behind a mask
he can do without a mask but you put him
behind something and he
this energy is like it's like a force of
nature and he's so
infinitely inventive ah please
before beauty thank you
i was so intimidated i mean i'm such a
huge fan of his and uh
just to watch him perform in his level
of commitment and he's such a great
actor
and so funny patchy
it's because i'm free isn't it his level
of invention on this movie
was off the charts and every day
i would be standing at the monitor
watching a take unfold
and my jaw would drop he'd just do
something you know remarkable makes him
a remarkable choice that
uh was uh yeah just kind of genius look
he's a genius
now you listen to me young lady even if
we're
horribly mangled there'll be no sad
faces on christmas
and who can forget this little scene
stealer
the grinch a young taylor mobsen
as cindy lou who i loved it
just coming to the set every day and
seeing everybody and acting the scene
out was just
a thrill for me aside from carrie and
momsen there was a
ton of star power in this film you heard
him officer
he admitted it i go with the pepper
spray
you have to make sure when this guy is
mad at the grinch you know my character
was the evil guy
he's mad he it's got to be you know
really something
my heart belongs to someone else
to kind of be his love interest in the
odd
uh character who you know
i mean for anyone to fall in love with
the grinch and yet it's this
this glamorous perfect little who who's
the town diva
but she thinks he's by far the most
interesting guy in town
martha made corvier has the best lights
well not this year i'm just a real sort
of kooky just obsessed with christmas
kind of
crazy mother i want everything to be
perfect and have everything go right
and let's not forget our favorite furry
dog slash reindeer
max brilliant
they want to spend a little quality time
with the grinch
i guess i could use a little social
interaction
it was about three and a half hours of
makeup and you know another half for the
suit and
then you just knocked on the coffin wall
and said i'm still alive
i'm still alive you know but you know
the funny thing
is something happens when they say
action you know and that's when the fun
begins
kerry told et back in 2000 that the
makeup process was almost too much to
bear
it takes you know a good hour or so to
scrape the stuff off my face and
whatever more
to get out of it it was an amazing
process because like two weeks of
absolute discomfort and kind of freaking
out about it and
thinking i don't know if i'm going to
get through this leading
hearts of the world unite the film's
makeup artist rick baker
revealed that ron howard actually
endured the uncomfortable grinch suit
himself
this is one of the few films where i
didn't suggest that but ron i think
actually came up with the idea and
thought
you know what maybe it'll be easier for
jim if he sees that i can do this too
you know he did for one day you know
and he had fun with after every take jim
would come over to the monitor and watch
it you know
and the two of them would discuss it and
and you know you see these you know you
see a tall branch in a short grinch
you know looking at the tv and then
talking to each other and talking like
that he was like
really funny site how the grinch stole
christmas went on to win the
oscar for best makeup and received
nominations for best art direction
and best costume design and the movie
became the third
highest grossing holiday film in the u.s
somebody's fabulous
i mean it was exciting enough to get the
queen of england to attend the london
premiere
well you know you get a little sheet of
paper and it tells you don't do this
don't do that you know it's it
basically says jim don't act on instinct
you know uh
anything that comes into your head
forget it no it's not it's not uh
allowed
tear up dude it's christmas well
obviously carrie and the cast did
something right because the movie's
impact is
everlasting but we all knew that this
was something
special and and you know it's like
there's there's a little kid in all of
us that is just like
that wants to be part of something that
just at christmas time
you just are dying to see
[Music]